welcome sir what's up what's going on
man uh you know
just I was just telling my boy that it
feels strange because it's a long time
to be back on the to be back on the
scene and doing know the promos and
doing stuff like that now it's podcast
like you and different type of things so
it's a little strange though but I'm
cool yeah man I mean look you've been
through it all you know what I'm saying
it's crazy cuz somehow like not a lot of
people can say that they have the
longevity to have been through every
like era of Music in terms of like you
went from cassettes to
CDs to
streaming
Napster I did all of it yeah again from
1988 to 2024 that's a long time that's a
long time man and it was so many
different hats whether it's being a
record executive whether it's being
behind the scenes producing records it's
just it's it's a lot man it's a I I
flashback on it again just it's a it's a
blessed career to be having and to still
be here and then being in front of y'all
doing you know with all the young people
and letting them know what time it is
you know a few things was going on and
and and sort of In The Name Of Music you
know yeah well like let me give you my
so I as uh I'm I'm 37 I just turned 37
so when I was a kid I first got hip to
death squad right yes so that was how I
was introduced to you cuz I was a Red
Man Fan right and Method Man and red man
and and and and that's how I got hip to
like Keith Murray but I was the kind of
kid who I still have all my source
magazines all my dou XS so I would go
back and like do my research on the Five
mik albums and stuff like that so the
first album of EPMD that I bought I
bought it used at the warehouse and it
was I think it was your's third album it
was the one that had the record with red
man and the record with LL yes that's
there yeah business as usual the Rampage
y with the cops on the front y yep yep
and um and so that was my first introdu
cuz I always like knew who EPMD EPMD
right so that was kind of like I had
it's crazy that you mentioned that
because that would that ended up getting
the full mic on that record right yep y
but it's funny like just like like like
my era of like hip-hop was like like
late '90s of course yeah I know early
2000s but I got to you know I got to
like kind of go back and like get the
the Brand newbi album and get all the
tribe [__] and get the EPMD [__] and
right so um but n man it's been dope to
see just kind of like your like
Evolution talk to me about like the new
project cuz it's you're doing like
collabs with everybody I know the new
singles got salt and pepper on it right
yeah well I had the idea during Co time
you know what I'm saying so Co stopped
things but before the hip-hop 50 I
always had ideas of just my
colleagues not being here I just figured
that you know you never know all of us
are still here yeah just because you got
young people we still have us that's
living too people want to hear music but
stop making music so I wanted to
facilitate that I wanted to be able to
say you know what let me make records on
people that come from the era that
people would love to hear if they was
able to make music so that's where the
dynamic duels came into play at so so I
want to get of course like it's like 25
rap groups yeah that are Duos right so
but I just picked it for the volume one
what I can get off now so for you it was
the inspiration was like let me do this
now cuz I have this idea now cuz like
you said during we were losing people
you never know when people are going to
be here not going to be here who alls on
the project yeah the project is loaded
it's um um I got Biggy smalles and
Tupac it's going to blow everybody's
away these are are these unheard
verses you it's it's not I don't to me
they are not um unheard but the way I
put it together okay it just sounds new
okay you know um um Lil Wayne
game um mob deep MLP red MEF do you have
mob deep and M on the same song no okay
okay these are just D Duos don't foret
two people okay two people on each song
okay and are you handing production
right Okay cyprus
Hills dog pound EPMD of
course
um this is impressive so far eight B MJG
woo
I think I I I caught everybody I think
mean a lot yeah that's a lot I I said
Snoop and Nate Dog right no you didn't
yeah Snoop and Nate Dog mhm
Jesus so for you like I always wonder as
a producer right like if you know like
let's say the biggie and the Tupac song
do you already have that beat made or do
you get the verses and do you no I have
it I
as a producer you got records you know
what I'm saying you make certain stuff
if you don't if you don't have it then
you make it I was going to say when you
hear those two verses from Biggy and
poac does that inspire you to make the
beat off of those verses or did you
already have that no I already had
something I wanted I wanted to make sure
that I I didn't want to make a regular
record I don't want to make it just a
hip-hop record I wanted the rock cuz
both of them is best best on Melody and
more R&B is type situations so that's
what I based my thing on when I had when
I was making it like okay I want to make
it as a a song song something that biggy
would rock on something that Pac would
rock on too it feel comfortable and most
of them they records are Melody yeah no
it's not really know the hip-hop you
know kicking you know we' had we had so
many uh different uh uh attempts at at
at wellknown producers that we all love
and know that haven't done the best job
I would say with certain Tupac or biggie
records after they passed I I I I like I
for me I just felt that it it it was
wasn't something that I was trying to do
to make the biggest F I just did what
felt good to me right that's day it was
we want something that I feel like it's
all about like if I could hear them like
actually being on that record when they
were alive that that Mak dope it makes
it crazy
because I think that they probably would
have been friends later on yeah I think
that all that beef for the stop
eventually because of what they had
before that but but but the way I did
that you would think they was in there
together oh that's fire I was going to
say um you had like a a really early
opportunity to work with biggie right
before before we really knew who he was
is that is yeah I mean yeah I
mean my story is ill on artists because
you have yeah you do have because you
know cuz but mindset is documented as
far as people talking yeah Rick Ross on
my basement 50 Cent in my basement
[__] ludicrous on my my door the game
wuang Clan rayin says I almost sign with
Eric like you know I mean this this
thing of
mes what I was able to um to see and and
and Biggy Smalls on my first video set
to well my man brought him to the barber
shop okay for me to see and then U when
I shot hitting switches My First Single
he was around the whole time why I do
every scene you know then he told Tracy
wer was like yo I want to go in that
sermon album but I already had artists
already and then I had you know I had my
own group so I wasn't trying to do
something new but at that time I could
have you know probably would have had
that did you cuz I know biggie had like
a a buzz going around New York but at
that time did you kind of see what
eventually ended up coming to be you
know like I I didn't again my
concentration wasn't on that because I
had my own you had your own [__] you
were put yeah yeah you know I had my own
his Squad was the biggest thing running
right you know like so that's effects
Red Man Eric I mean EPMD with the
biggest [__] running so it was like so
at the time it wasn't me looking at
anything else you know